Cháy đừng ông khi đó ẩm ở Malaysia, hơn 1 trong 4 vỷ thương.
Bù cháy sẽ giá vào sáng ngày 1 tăng tư tại bằng xây lần gó,
cạnh thủ đô của la Lam Pua của Malaysia,
sau giờ gì trên đoạn đừng ông khi đó dài khoảng 60 mấy của công phía dầu khi nhận nước Pé Chôn At.
Sau khi vù cháy sẽ giá, Pé Chôn At đã đam văn của đường ẩm.
Ý vùi chio, lực lượng cứ hoả đã không chế được hỏi lượng.
Giới chức Malaysia cho biết chương khi nhận nạn nhân thiệt mạng trong vụ cháy,
hơn 1 trong 4 vỷ thương và sống mới người trong số này đã nhập việt.
Họng năng mấy người nhà bị anh gồm gọi đám trái, theo dửa khu hỏi địa phương.
Sa nhà nông như mặt trảo trên biết,
tôi cảm thấy như đăng bị thư đốt,
một người dân địa phương cho hay.